alors que la crise sanitaire se
transforme progressivement en crise
économique mettant de nombreux français
sur le carreau voilà qu'une décision au
plus haut niveau de l'état fait déjà
débat dans les députés eux ne
connaissent pas la crise
leur enveloppe de frais va être augmenté
de 15% en effet c'est le député de
l'assemblée nationale florent bacheliers
qui a pris la décision d'augmenter de
15% le portefeuille de dotation de tous
les députés qui ne s'agit pas de leur
salaire il s'agit tout de même d'une
enveloppe qui leur permet la prise en
charge d'un certain nombre de dépenses
parmi lesquels les courses en taxi ou en
vtt les dépenses téléphoniques ou de
courriers par exemple en cette période
difficile cette dotation annuelle est
passée de 18 mille neuf cent cinquante
euros à 21500 euros
un changement que certains dénoncent
c'est le cas par exemple de la députée
la république en marche l'organe rossi
augmenter cette enveloppe dans le
contexte actuel ne se justifiait pas
c'est très difficilement explicable de
son côté eric ciotti persiste et signe
pour lui cette polémique n'a pas lieu
d'être cette augmentation est légitime
surtout qu'elle ne coûtera pas plus cher
aux contribuables puisque elle a été
financée par les économies réalisées par
l'assemblée nationale alors
l'enveloppent des députés augmente un
scandale florian bacheliers députés en
marche et avec nous ce soir
pour répondre à cette polémique
merci pour relier d'être avec nous merci
beaucoup merci pas c'est moi qui vous
remercie très élégant plus lorient alors
on va exposer bien sûr no doubt un ici
comme tous les téléspectateurs chez eux
en direct à 20h01
mais y en a quand même qui disent que
c'est pas un scandale qui comprennent
alors on va écouter d'abord les noms et
après bien sûr on aura la réponse de
flore est oui alors pour moi c'est pas
un scandale déjà parce qu'on parle pas
du salaire des députés c'est les frais
donc les frais c'est les taxis les frais
professionnels etc
donc j'imagine que s'ils sont augmentés
c'est pour une raison ensuite en ce
moment les côtes françaises perdent des
milliards d'euros là j'ai calculé 577
députés
on parle d'un million d'euros à peine
sur un an mais franchement c'est
ridicule c'est pas un scandale pour moi
alors bon c'est le symbole qu'est
scandale oui vous avez déjà vous les
députés 7400 euros brut par mois plus
des indemnités de frais délirante des
enveloppes massive plein davantage les
français qui aujourd'hui voit
l'électricité le gaz augmente et les
timbres augmenté on leur donne pas plus
d'argent pour qu'il paye tout ça et vous
les députés des privilégiés vous allez
vous gaver encore plus c'est ce qu'on
répondra tout à l'heure j'aimerais avoir
un nom non mais tu peux pas garder ça
d'abord c'est une équipe un
parlementaire c'est une équipe il a des
gens à payer les frais en quelques
années le scandale pourquoi est-ce qu'on
va reprocher un député d'abord une rom
qui augmente continue travail qui le
souhaiteraient commente aujourd'hui
jamais que le timing soit mauvais
peut-être là mais excusez moi un essai
sur des gens qui travaillent énormément
et qui se sont tous ont des gens à
rémunérer et des frais a assurément
c'est tout à fait normal enfin elle fait
aimer mais les notes de frais de toute
façon tout le monde sait que tout le
monde on use et en abuse les notes de
frais fort pas chez moi ouais j'ai vu
deux paquets de bonbons crebassa chier
des bulles car oui alors je pique et
puis surtout c'est vraiment une question
timing a aujourd'hui des gens avec la
crise qui se suicident parce qu'ils sont
la panade niveau financier niveau
professionnel alors comment est ce que
vous politique vous pouvez faire
tellement un clivage entre le peuple et
vous en augmentant des notes de frais
alors nous excitons et à tout ça on
parle pas de notes de frais des sociétés
privées un label d'argent inuit non pas
juste il faut juste retombée
c'est stratégiquement une erreur de
communication incroyable comment mais
quelle est la personne qui a pu avoir
une idée très grand
comment on peut avoir une telle idée
maintenant je veux dire là ça ne peut
pas passer les français n'ont jamais été
aussi mal et on est en pleine crise
c'est là on parle d'une problématique de
députés qui voudraient augmenter de 15%
ses frais c'est un truc c'est effroyable
de prendre une telle décision alors
butoir vous allez répondre bien entendu
dans un instant la jeunesse un peu faire
le tour de table à langer raguine
maillet qui est aussi colère oui non
d'autant plus que ma kron a dit quoi
qu'il en coûte donc lors qu'il en coûte
parce que c'est la crise sanitaire pour
les français et vous vous augmente alors
j'ai entendu monsieur castaner ce matin
chez bourdin il disait que c'était pour
le courrier les taxis et les téléphones
en gros c'était ces frais là alors le
courrier j'ai envie de vous dire à
envoyer des mails les taxis m'a fait
comme les citoyens prenez le métro
prenait prenez le rer et regarder
quelles sont les conditions aujourd'hui
des citoyens puisque vous êtes des élus
de la nation c'est bien aussi de se
rapprocher des gens des vrais gens et
voilà pour le reste effectivement il a
tout dit gilot si c'est effectivement un
symbole qui est complètement indécent
jeudi dans la période vous répondre à
tout le monde c'est vrai que là tu as
beaucoup d' attaque un florian mais il
le savait jeanne mas oui j'ai du mal à
me reconnaître
oui alors moi je suis moi je suis moins
con ce clivage mais effectivement le
message est totalement inappropriée en
ce moment que vous ayez tort ou à raison
on s'en fout ce sera mal jugé et mal
interprétés donc été sur le genre de
communiqué de là dessus maintenant est
de le dire je pense sincèrement que ça
pouvait attendre
on a eu beaucoup de critiques et un
instant c'est normal forcément quand on
annonce une telle mesure forcément
l'opinion publique se dit pourquoi
comment c'est inadmissible
et on peut le comprendre c'est parti
d'un article je crois qui est sorti sur
capital.fr wii est derrière tout le
monde a repris mais l'info c'est là
qu'elle en fait la façon dont s'est
présentée c'est hyper chaud quand même
si on m'explique que les députés se sont
augmentés évident je me twin le segment
c c mais c'est juste pas ça en réalité
ce que je veux dire ça ne parle pas de
la rémunération de l'indemnité des élus
des députés ça n'est absolument pas ça
la deuxième chose que je veux dire c'est
que on a depuis le début réalisé 55
millions d'euros d'économie d'argent
public moi quand je suis rentré je viens
pas de la politique alors je voulais le
dire aussi une petite question parce que
vous étiez avocat oui voilà vous vous
avez gagné beaucoup mieux votre vie en
tant qu'avocat content de député on peut
le dire comme ça alors c'est vrai c'est
moi c'est de l'ordre de
trois fois oui oui oui oui oui on va
dire comme ça pourquoi vous êtes devenu
député vous était pas mieux vaut qu'à
ses pairs que des emmerdes
non mais tout simplement parce que c'est
aussi la raison pour laquelle j'ai eu la
chance de devenir avocat c'est parce que
l'état français à payer ma bourse
d'étude est par exemple m'a offert un
logement universitaire pendant sept ans
à venir
voilà j'aime et que je devais rendre un
pays beaucoup de ce qui m'avait donné et
et que j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
le président emmanuel macron en 2016 et
que on est parti sur un projet pour un
élu et peu importe la sensibilité
politique c'est ça qu'il faut juste
parfois se dire c'est là pour aider pour
servir la sensibilité à la base six mois
j'étais strauss kahniens notre parti
avec le parti socialiste au départ date
au centre où ça vient on accorde bien
les choses ok alors on est donc donc sur
les 55 millions d'euros d'économies sur
trois ans on va ajouter environ 30
millions d'économies cette année en 2020
pourquoi parce qu'il ya plus de
déplacements il ya plus beaucoup de
déplacements donc on va arriver autour
de 85 millions d'euros l'objectif fixé
sur les cinq ans d'être à 100 millions
d'euros d'euros de l'économie d'économie
pourquoi vous êtes vous fera vous avez
augmenté pour frais c'est ce que veulent
savoir les français parce que sinon on
va voir le sondage dans un instant ils
sont pas d'accord mais je veux vous dire
justin pour expliquer de quoi on parle
on parle de 100 millions d'euros
d'économie d'argent public et d'une
affectation budgétaire réaffectation
budgétaire de 800 mille euros c'est de
ça dont kkr donc c'est la pièce d'un
euro versus le billet de 100 euros
c'est bon pour dire les faveurs de
kendra et replantation de calais 800000
euros qui vont être dépensées plr.les la
raison en est simple
en fait c'est la pandémie c'est le fait
qu' on est une organisation une
organisation un peu particulière c'est
577 représentants de la nation il rentre
en circonscription ils viennent
travailler à l'assemblée nationale mais
leurs collaborateurs aujourd'hui comme
dans n'importe quelle organisation ils
sont télétravail donc ils ont besoin de
matériel pour beaucoup plus pour
communiquer sa clique mon cher etc
c'est pour ça que vous n'avez plus le
ferai évidemment ni vis-à-vis des
vis-à-vis des citoyens pour maintenir le
lien parce qu'on n'arrive plus à se voir
on peut plus organiser de réunions
publiques etc
on a en communique autrement et pour
répondre à la question de tout à l'heure
mais pourquoi vous n'envoyez pas de mail
c'était mon premier réflexe moi au
départ mais parce que quand vous envoyez
des mails vous avez beaucoup moins de
retour et vous avez beaucoup moins
lien et moi je crois qu'on vit un moment
et c'est aussi pour ça que je me suis
engagé tout au début en 2017
il faut qu'on retisse par tout moyen de
lien de confiance entre les élus et peu
importe leur bord politique et les
citoyens
plus on se parle mieux ça ça leur juste
niveau et là pardon c'est une
réaffectation analyses budgétaires pour
mieux et plus se parler on est on est
quasiment en mode hot line depuis dix
mois
on sert jour et nuit les les français
pour leur des pour essayer de les aider
sur sur juste sur le souhaitent ils ont
à ce jour et revenir parce que c'est
vous qui est à l'origine de cette
augmentation des frais aux députés
pourquoi les timbrés courrier donc pas
ce que vous faites peu de courrier
alors c'est bien vu voilà parce qu'il ya
plus il ya plus de correspondances mais
il ya plus de gens qui vous écrive oui
on a été officiellement ouvert il serait
plus au moins se voit pas on sait à caen
très bien je peux vous donner un exemple
la semaine dernière j'en parlais tout à
l'heure j'ai écrit à l'ensemble des
soignants psychiatres psychologues de ma
circonscription pour leur dire un déjà
merci pour tout ce qu'ils font n'a comme
que j'avais quand même là tu sais à peu
près pardon c'est combien de lettres
c'est à peu près ça c'est c'est environ
65 lettres accorde donc il a droit y est
il atteint bresse a donc tous les faits
a séché respect pour leur dire on a
conscience du fait que la psychiatrie
française aujourd'hui est dans une
situation compliquée encore plus du fait
de la pandémie et donc pour leur dire
que le président la république avait
annoncé l'ouverture d' assises sur de la
psychiatrie cet été et que au quatrième
point j'avais besoin moi en tant que
représentant de la nation de leur retour
d'expérience et d'expérience pour bien
alimenter un dossier pour avoir des
choses sérieuses à dire que c'est un
premier temps je vous l'envoyer par
courrier vous avez des retours d'un zoom
vous avez déjà faire un zoom avec tout
le monde attendait oui c'est juste c'est
fait plusieurs tours et à zoom zoom
plusieurs noms mais c'est exactement ce
qu'on va faire avec les réponses qu'on a
déjà engrangé on est en train
d'organiser prenait gouvernement salle à
une visioconférence fin à la fin du
match aller on va voir ce qu'on va voir
le sondage
alors oui mais voilà on s'en doutait
j'ai bien fait d'abandonner si l'on
s'est ajouté un point
oui allez peut-être pour gratter un
point à l'ennemi pas ses petits voir ça
ici quand je suis arrivé à l'assemblée
nationale j'ai été choqué par ce qui
existait il y avait un régime spécial de
retraite des députés supprimés il y
avait les billets de train pour le
député honoraire à vie
supprimée il y avait des avantages pour
les anciens présidents supprimer un
régime spécial de protection chômage
ddd des députés supprimés on avait toute
une série justement de choses qui nous
choquer moi je vais vous dire j'ai pas
de chauffeur j'ai pas de voiture en tant
que questeurs et j'ai le droit
voilà reviennent je n'ai pas besoin je
sais que je sais que tu as refusé d'en
mais c'est vrai et on a mis en place une
direction des ressources humaines une
direction des achats ça n'existait pas
on a embauché un responsable des achats
de chez coca cola pour dire une marque à
l'antenne pardon alors on va dire pepsi
cola conquis le beau gars on met en
place les méthodes qui existent dans
toutes les organisations justement pour
dépoussiérer et c'est ça qui permet de
faire les économies et ses économies là
eh ben c'est pas juste pour faire des
économies c'est pour réinjecter dans les
moyens y en a par exemple réduit de cent
soixante dix le nombre de fonctionnaires
de l'assemblée nationale alors on va
voir on va voir si c'est augmenter
mais bon c'est toujours toujours pas
voter non mais si vous pouvez voter bien
merci en tout cas nous avoir extrait
voilà même si ou alors y en a plein qui
sont pas d'accord au moins il est venu
nous expliquer franchement merci florian
bacheliers d'avoir été là et on espère
qu'il va y avoir ces économies de 100
millions
comme vous avez dit sur cinq ans parce
que là j'espère aussi que ça sortira
dans la presse et que on le saura
évidemment et je redis ce n'est pas la
rémunération des députés absolument pas
ce serait totalement indécent et ça
coûte pas un centime d'euro aux français
des centres r&d